linguistics isn't just the study of
words or sounds it's a study of all the
parts of conversation that includes
gesture analysis which looks at Co
speech gestures not postural gaze but
winking or sticking out your tongue or
how arms and hands move alongside speech
just to be clear this isn't about sign
languages those are systematically
governed with elaborate syntax and
vocabulary signed languages are language
but gestures are paralinguistic they
accompany language gesture analysts make
their job easier by talking about
different categories of gestures which
explain how they relate to meaning and
those are number one iconic these
gestures represent a literal object like
a flat surface or a car weaving through
traffic number 2 metaphoric gestures
that symbolize an abstract concept like
before-and-after or working together I
do that a lot and on this green screen
those metaphoric gestures become a bit
more literal with the help of graphics
apologies to my animator three day
acting that's pointing to things
positioning yourself to people or places
or things like pointing behind the
camera or over there number four
pragmatics like offering the floor to
someone or don't bother me right now and
finally beat the rhythm of gestures
alongside the natural stress patterns of
speech all these categories I'm I'm
really self-conscious about every move
I'm making now um
these categories can coexist as well
often gestures that are performed on
beat also fit into another category
there's one more type of gesture that
serves a slightly different purpose
emblems emblems are named gestures that
don't have to occur alongside speech to
have meaning like thumbs up it has a
meaning outside of the context of speech
in order world you can flash some on the
thumbs up and they will almost certainly
understand that you are signaling
approval or that everything's okay but
if you swap the fingers it doesn't have
the same meaning and even if I stick
with the thumb if I change angle and arm
position I'm trying to hitchhike the
form of the gesture is tied to the
established meaning it is an emblem
which means it's not Universal the
meaning is learned and context and
change it that thumbs up in some
countries it used to be rude but because
of globalization that's no longer the
common reading there although there will
be people who remember it's rude history
and could still interpret it that way
emblems can change definition over time
they can be
created they can be forgotten I would
demonstrate that by dabbing but I don't
want a gif of that to haunt me for the
rest of my life so why do we do it
what does gesturing actually accomplish
well first redundancy for decoding and
encoding errors languages have agreement
all over the place there's redundancy
baked into everything spoken language is
ephemeral when something is said it's
gone
those sound waves have moved on and they
are not coming back gesture is another
form of redundancy it doesn't matter if
a loud by it just the wrong time you may
have figured out a vague idea of what
was being said next you can show
emphasis and importance or if you're
explaining abstract concept using
metaphoric gestures to visibly explain
things can help make it clear either to
your conversation partner or just in
your own head and sometimes it is so
much easier and clearer just a point
gestures are important to communication
and so important that if our hands and
arms are unavailable we all use our head
our eyes are our other limbs to
compensate gestures can also show
understanding of social norms if you're
embarrassed to say something you can
make that clear by covering your face or
your eyes or by doing the move that
looks like there are no paper towels or
hand dryers in this bathroom so I guess
I'll just shake it off or if you want to
distance yourself from what you're
saying you can use scare quotes or you
can put a boundary around yourself
gestures also seem to help us get the
words out in the first place that's why
people gesture even when they're on the
phone and why people have been blind
since birth gesture gesture is intrinsic
to language it helps us communicate more
effectively and more elaborately and to
pass on information and feelings that
are difficult to put into words gestures
are basically emoji for the real world
one of my co-authors Gretchen McCulloch
has a book called because Internet all
about Internet language you can find out
more at the links in the description
you